aujourd'hui on va pas faire de vidéo je
la tournerai plutôt demain mais demain
je tourne un spectacle pour ma chaîne du
coup on la fera dans 6 mois cette vidéo
Ciao
salut aujourd'hui j'avais la flemme de
faire cette vidéo franchement je
l'aurais bien été calé à demain j'avais
donc envie de procrastiner procrastique
quoi procrastiner c'est remettre à
demain ce qu'on aurait pu faire
aujourd'hui c'est ça que ça veut dire
c'est prendre son téléphone pour envoyer
un message important et s'apercevoir une
heure après qu'on est toujours sur le
téléphone qu'on scroll sur Tik Tok et
qu'on a toujours pas envoyé le message
est-ce que j'ai des astuces mais genre
des choses simples des trucs faciles à
faire efficaces et oui bien sûr et pour
moi c'est c'est une question de survie
parce que c'est peut-être pas clair pour
vous mais je suis un énorme
procrastinateur j'ai une bouse là-dedans
je suis pas configuré pour être motivé
du coup quand j'ai pas le temps j'ai
plein d'idées que j'aimerais faire dès
que j'ai le temps je les fais pas alors
ça va de trucs basiques genre j'ai
trouvé une super recette là je vais
aller faire les courses et ce soir je me
fais une grosse session de cuisine à
j'ai une super idée de vidéo je vais
l'écrire et dès que j'ai le temps pour
le faire bon ben vous êtes mentaliste
vous aussi vous avez déjà de vidéo il y
a longtemps j'ai découvert que quand on
est procrastinateur c'est pour toute la
vie donc voilà au lieu d'abandonner j'ai
inventé un concept devenir
procrastinateur abstinent alors
attention je vais pas vous bombarder de
dizaines d'astuces mais seulement des
plus utiliser et à tenir dans le temps
sinon vous allez faire comme moi vous
allez procrastiner à utiliser l'astuce
et on s'en sort pas et c'est trop près
de la caméra que ça soit pour faire des
trucs simples de la vie normale pour les
cours pour étudier pour des projets
professionnels regardez bien la vidéo
jusqu'au bout parce que je vais vous
donner exactement les astuces que
j'utilise et qui m'ont permis quand même
de faire des vidéos dont une par jour
pendant un an en 2016 ici là sur Youtube
décrire des spectacles d'écrire des
livres et même de sellier quand même le
dernier Zelda parce qu'il faut pas
déconner non plus et l'outil ultime je
vous le donnerai à la toute fin bah
ouais la première astuce c'est la grande
boucherie le grand découpage ce qui fait
procrastiner le plus c'est le stress et
l'angoisse qui se développe dans votre
cerveau quand vous êtes prêt à faire
quelque chose mais que ce quelque chose
paraît énorme c'est hyper décourageant
et c'est ce stress qui va vous faire
reporter à demain puis à jamais comme
dans Bref
dès que vous avez quelque chose à faire
découpez-le en petites choses faciles à
réaliser si je dois faire ma recette la
première tâche à faire c'est de faire ma
liste de courses bon bah déjà que je
fasse ça et ensuite on verra si je peux
y aller si je dois réviser pour mon
diplôme une matière alors je vais
commencer par écrire toutes les petites
tâches que ça implique genre réunir mes
cours faire une liste de quelques vidéos
qui parlent du sujet pour ma freiner
faire une liste des grands thèmes à
réviser par exemple etc on appelle ça
méthode des petits pas la méthode Kaizen
et je vous jure si vous devez faire
qu'une seule astuce choisissez celle-là
et quand ça sera devenu un réflexe pour
vous une habitude vous pourrez rajouter
d'autres astuces ça va éliminer le
stress que votre idée vous provoque et
surtout ça va réaliser un truc génial
dans votre cerveau dont je vous parle
dans la prochaine astuce la deuxième
astuce c'est de s'abonner à cette chaîne
et d'activer la cloche parce que là bon
vous croyez que vous êtes abonné puis là
vous êtes en train de vérifier en bas et
vous vous dites ah ben non pourtant ça a
l'air vachement bien ces vidéos alors
que si je m'abonne je pourrais le
retrouver plus facilement ce petit
bonhomme arrêtez de m'appeler mon petit
bonhomme la deuxième astuce c'est une
sorte de drogue mais elle est légal
parce que c'est votre cerveau qui la
fabrique d'ailleurs dites-vous bien que
pour trouver gagner du temps pour se
motiver pour réaliser une idée ou un
projet ce sont les mêmes processus qui
fonctionnent dans le cerveau en gros en
comprenant comment le cerveau fonctionne
vous allez mieux savoir quoi faire alors
faites des listes partez pas je vous
explique des listes plutôt sur des
carnets ou sur du papier d'ailleurs pas
sur votre téléphone je vous dirai pour
que tout à l'heure des listes avec tout
en utilisant la première astuce vous
allez découper plein plein d'étapes vous
en faites une liste et quand vous allez
rayer une tâche vous allez avoir dans
votre cerveau un petit shot de dopamine
c'est l'hormone du bonheur que votre
cerveau va libérer pour vous récompenser
ça s'appelle le circuit de la récompense
et ça marche beaucoup mieux en riant
quelque chose qu'on voit encore sur une
feuille donc avec l'action physique quoi
de faire ça que d'appuyer sur un bouton
pour effacer une note ça c'est beaucoup
moins efficace alors évidemment c'est
mieux de classer un petit peu votre
liste je reviendrai plus tard sur une
très bonne méthode très rapide pour le
faire mais mettez déjà en haut de votre
liste ce qui est urgent puisqu'il est
important et enfin tout le reste ça vous
donnera une meilleure vision on peut
faire encore mieux mais c'est déjà un
bon point de départ troisième astuce
facile dites non non et non allez-y
c'est à VOUS j'entends rien mais vous
pouvez mettre en commentaires non je
dirais pas vous dites NON pour avoir
plus de temps pour vous au moment où
vous alliez dire oui par facilité on est
tous comme ça franchement c'est pas dur
à faire prenez toujours le temps avant
d'accepter de faire quelque chose mais
ça serait cool qu'on part d'une semaine
en camping entre potes tu t'occupes de
réserver les trains ben non en fait non
c'est ton idée à toi elle est cool donc
fais-le quatrième astuce ça va être
vitesse folle bloquer deux heures dans
la semaine pour faire ce que vous voulez
vraiment je déconne pas c'est comme ça
que j'ai pu entamer tout ce que je fais
aujourd'hui parce que sinon tu as une
super idée tu en parles à tout le monde
un jour je vais faire ça quand j'aurai
le temps je vais prendre un moment c'est
sûr ça je vais le faire c'est sûr hein
tu vas le faire ah oui tu vas le faire
dans 1000 ans par contre environ mais tu
vas le faire en bloquant ces deux heures
chaque semaine comme à sanctuaire que
personne pourrait annuler vous allez
toujours avancer sur cette idée qui vous
tient vraiment à cœur parce que ça ça va
vous alléger le cerveau et ça va vous
faire du bien au coeur en cinquième
astuce je pourrais vous parler de la
matrice d'alisano World comment je fais
pour identifier les racines d'une
motivation pour persévérer quand j'ai
plus envie de pourquoi je dis que seul
on va plus vite ensemble on va plus loin
ou pas de commanderie dans les mots m'a
débloquer un truc dans le cerveau de
comment j'ai plus de temps pour glander
et jouer à la console depuis que je
procrastine plus bref en 5e astuce je
vais juste vous dire deux choses la
première c'est que vous pouvez faire ce
que vous fait plaisir et ce que vous
devez faire sans vraiment de difficulté
si moi j'ai réussi en partant d'aussi
loin c'est vraiment que c'est pas très
contraignant sinon j'aurais abandonné la
deuxième c'est que j'ai tout mis dans un
livre qui vient de sortir oui j'écris
des livres qui était juste là et qui
s'appelle votre idée va devenir une
réalité j'aurais pu l'appeler faites
enfin ce que vous voulez en allant au
bout sans culpabiliser parce que vous
reportez trop de choses et qu'en fait
vous avez un peu plus de temps que ça
mais c'était un peu long donc j'ai
choisi ce titre je sais pas d'ailleurs
si vous aviez lu votre temps est infini
que j'avais fait en 2018 mais si vous
aviez aimé votre temps est infini vous
allez adorer celui-là et si vous n'avez
pas lu votre temps est infini vous allez
adorer celui-là c'est gagnant en plus je
vous parle même pas de l'acheter
d'ailleurs vous pouvez prendre à la
bibliothèque dans une médiathèque où
vous le faire prêter par quelqu'un qui
l'a déjà mais je suis sûr de ce que j'ai
mis dedans et je pense vraiment qu'il
peut aider pas mal de personnes sur le
temps la procrastination la réalisation
donc trouver un moyen de le lire moi
j'aurais bien aimé de l'avoir il y a 15
ans et c'est la raison pour laquelle je
l'ai écrit d'ailleurs les exemples que
je prends dedans pour expliquer les
méthodes que j'ai utilisées qui viennent
de la science du cerveau etc et de son
fonctionnement ça vient aussi de mon
expérience c'est facile à comprendre
c'est
utile et applicable à peu près tout en
fait je vous fais voir un peu le
sommaire détaillé vous pouvez faire
pause pour regarder un peu ça dans le
détail le livre est dispo dans toutes
les librairies oui même celle à côté de
chez toi non tu as pas poussé la porte
depuis un petit moment passe les voir il
est aussi dispo sur Amazon cultura Fnac
tous les trucs habituels je vais vous
mettre tous les liens dans la
description il y a aussi disponible en
ebook et en version audio lui par ma
petite voix évidemment et lui aussi
dispo en Suisse en Belgique au Canada
les checker chez vos libraires et sinon
si on se voit à mon spectacle je vous le
signerez avec plaisir à la fin du show
j'en profite aussi pour vous remercier
ça fait 7 ans maintenant que j'écris des
livres on les trouve dans 15 pays c'est
une aventure avec vous et j'essaie
toujours d'écrire des choses qui
pourront vous être utiles dans votre vie
des vraies choses pratiques pas des
formules magiques mais les solutions que
j'ai d'abord dû trouver pour moi c'est
pour ça qu'elle existe vraiment moi je
m'appelle toujours Fabien olicard le
livre est dans la bio prenez bien soin
de vous merci de m'avoir donné
l'opportunité encore d'écrire un livre
j'espère qu'il vous sera utile à très
bientôt Ciao